I only applied to Cambridge got into
Cambridge and I thought that was going
to be the beginning of my full agency it
was actually the beginning of the end
and uh I
suddenly was exposed to sort of a
culture
of critical theories which told me that
I was a victim and that I was at an
inherent
disadvantage and that really messed with
my mind I got very depressed was an
anti-depressant was suicidal for my
second
year yes it wasn't going very well I was
very quickly exposed to critical theory
critical race Theory particularly and
the assumption that because I was black
I was therefore inevitably going to join
all the all these black societies which
I did but it became very apparent that I
was very native African and because of
that
there was a disconnect in terms of our
morality a disconnect in terms of how I
saw myself and how they saw
me the other problem was that can I just
stop you let's delve into that because
what you just said there was so
interesting to me about how you saw
yourself how they saw me and because I
was a native African my morality was
different let's really unpack that what
do you mean by that I think my in terms
of being native African I think it
doesn't when it comes to me it doesn't
really sort of pertain to sort of the
stereotypical native African I think
even in South Africa it was very
different to most black South African
children because I lived and socialized
exclusively with white South Africans I
was fostered by a white South African
family so I was very much I saw myself
as white uh I really did and I didn't
really understand why other people
didn't see me as white and fortunately
in South Africa I was able to play into
that very much because of how I spoke
because I'd always be hand in hand with
a morbidly obese Pentecostal Christian
woman so um it was okay um but coming
here and being here it was very
different in terms of how people saw me
and wanted me to act especially in
relation to seeing
white people as being oppressive to me
when in fact throughout my life it was
white people who cared for me it was
white people who loved me it was white
people who gave me purpose and meaning
never in my life did black South
Africans want to Foster me wanted to
adopt me I'd been abandoned by my black
mother so there was an inherent
contradiction in what I was being told
especially at University and the fact
that I was expected to very much
assimilate into this narrative and into
a community that
really conflicted with everything that I
believed and had experienced and as an
out from an outsider's point of view
what do you think about the way we talk
about race in this country the way we
perceive it the way
it's the narratives that are propagated
through our society about
it I find it incredibly unfree I think
for a lot of people I think it's unfree
for black people because I would say in
this country there is now this very
Americanized perspective
that everything can be reduced to some
kind of institutional or structural
which disproportionately affects people
of color specifically black people and
it doesn't matter about the empirical
reality of for instance all the black
people who I knew at Cambridge were
incredibly wealthy black people some of
their parents were famous you know they
sort of were doing quite well for
themselves had gone to private school
but they were oppressed and they really
lived by that identity and it didn't
it didn't correspond to what was
actually going on it sounds just
incredibly sad because you're denying
that you have agency in the world and
that's so disempowering how are you
going to improve yourself how are you
going to build a career how are you
going to get married or do whatever it
is that you want to do if you don't
believe that you have agency you you're
literally
powerless yes
yes yes um yes and I defin I definitely
especially when I was at University I
definitely felt that and I experienced
that I was in despair like constant
despair for days and I didn't know what
to do with myself I didn't know how I
was going
to navigate the world because what was
the point what's the point in trying to
do things when inevitably I'm going to
fail because I'm black and the systems
and institutions are against me and you
end up fulfilling that prophecy just in
yourself and
um yes yes I but that's so remarkable
because you're a young woman who is at
Cambridge University one of the best
universities in the world you get a
degree from there your opportunities are
Limitless you can pretty much go into
any industry you want any country you
want and yet you're a victim with it I
mean it's it's it's just bollocks yes
technical term yeah yes yes it
definitely is bollocks and it's was so
unhealthy especially for me as somebody
who didn't get on with the black people
who I was in association with and they
didn't like me as well it wasn't just
one-sided but I was expected to somehow
be in Allegiance with these people who I
didn't have any personal Affinity
with and then not with wide people who I
actually like culturally had a lot more
in common with sort of was able
to it just made a lot more sense to me
and the consequence of that is that I
was called racist and sort of uh
self-hating black which is something
that I'm always accused of and
and I think because people especially my
generation care a lot about what
everybody else thinks a lot uh even
though it's all about sort of me me me
me me um it's always with the lens of
somebody else and everybody else
narcissism always needs the supply yes
it needs the supply that's the good
stuff definitely
definitely